bei temperaturen von minus zehn bis
minus 20 grad celsius laufen ihre huskys
zur bild formen auf und doch silvia
furtwängler ist in ihrem element
die deutsche zählt zu den besten
schlitten hundeführern der welt jeden
tag trainiert für bevorstehende rennen
in einer traumhaften
natur
es läuft schön es ist still ist es ist
nicht laut die hunde hecheln gewinnt der
immer da ist wenn wir nicht da ist dann
macht man sich gedanken
es ist ganz schön ich genieße es es ist
ihr traum sagt die 56-jährige den sie
hier leben kann
vor neun jahren auf eine expedition in
decke sie den einsamen landstrich für
sich ließ deutschland hinter sich und
wanderte mit ihrem mann und ihrem
jüngsten sohn denn die norwegische
provinz aus 37 norwegische huskies im
schlepptau
wir sind glaube ich ein stück weit wie
ich also die rasse sowieso auch sind
sind einzelgänger aber auch teamfähig
sind familienmenschen aber doch auch
machen ihr eigenes ding auch und jeder
um den wir haben einen sinn
sie sind eine frohnatur also wenn man es
sich mit den hunden nicht verscherzt
dann hat man noch ein partner fürs leben
ich find das toll
das haus der furtwänglers liegt
abgeschieden direkt an einem see im
sommer nur mit einem boot zu erreichen
im winter mit dem snowmobil
die nächste stadt liegt 60 kilometer
entfernt oft sind sie hier in der
herdecker wieder der größten hochebene
europas wochenlang von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten
es ist nicht immer so einfach das hört
sich alles an ist es toll uns das
romantik sind bekommen sie besuch der
nächste nachbar ist kilometerweit
entfernt es ist ein raues volk hier und
das ist es auch am anfang das ist es so
sie haben jetzt nicht die willkommens
mentalität wie jetzt und spanien sagte
ok fiesta und siesta und was weiß ich
und wir feiern
die gucken erst mal an und sagen wir
wollen erst mal abwarten ob die den
ersten winter überleben
mittlerweile sind wir angekommen um
gleich wieder durchzustarten 600
kilometer mit dem schlitten durch
russland sie ist die einzige frau unter
den teilnehmern und nur sind gelangt ans
ziel
kaiser und kämpft sie sich auch 1600
kilometer durch alaska beim
internationalen schlittenrennen yukon
quest ist auch bei magath re trennen
dabei einem der härtesten eine tortur
für mensch und tier
als ich die ziellinie überquert habe da
war mir klar egal was kommt in meinem
leben wie ich schaffen alles das extreme
dieses das hat ja nicht nur was damit zu
tun sind die hunde drauf und bin ich gut
drauf das ist das mentale das ist so
dieses eins sein mit der natur mit den
tieren mit dir selber schaffe ich es
allen widrigkeiten die da auf mich
zukommen zu trotzen
aufgeben kommt für sie nicht in frage
im sport wie im leben ihren platz hat
sie hier gefunden
irgendwo in der norwegischen wildnis
1300 kilometer von deutschland entfernt
heimat ist für mich da wo ich mich wohl
fühle und wo meine familie sich wohl
fühlt und das ist hier heimat ist nicht
deutschland
ursprung ist deutschland aber heimat ist
jetzt der platz hier
eis und schnee
extreme kälte und extremen
lebensbedingungen
das ist das was silvia furtwängler
glücklich macht